breaking news on capitol hill where the
first major gun control legislation in
decades is expected to get final
approval in congress later today now
it's already passed the senate with
bipartisan support and president biden
plans to sign it into law anti-cordis is
at the white house with more on this
story nancy good morning they say this
is a big big deal it is a milestone gale
this bill is poised to become the most
significant federal bipartisan gun law
we've seen in decades 15 republicans
joining all senate democrats last night
in voting yes now this is the result of
weeks of closed-door talks in the senate
following the uvalde massacre in texas
lead negotiators for the bill said that
congress just could no longer ignore the
nation's gun violence
i don't believe in doing nothing
in the face
of what we saw in uvalde and we've seen
in far too many communities this bill is
a compromise
it doesn't do everything i want
but what we are doing will save
thousands of lives
this bipartisan legislation is going to
enhance gun background checks for people
under the age of 21. it sets aside 750
million dollars to give to states that
implement red flag laws which are
designed to temporarily seize guns from
people who are deemed a danger to
themselves or others and it closes the
so-called boyfriend loophole which
prevents someone who's been convicted of
a domestic abuse a crime but lives
outside of a victim's home from buying a
gun now this is nowhere near what
democrats wanted it doesn't restrict the
sale of assault weapons it doesn't
restrict the sale of high-capacity
magazines but negotiators tell me that
what was more important here was to show
that congress could get something done
on gun safety after years of failure
nate
nancy thank you